Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Freddy Fazbear's Pizzeria Simulator.
Now I have been playing this game in a way some might misconstrue
as being illogical, horrifying and death defying
But that's the only way that I can play this game and still call myself the king of Five Nights at Freddy's
because there is an easy way to play this game
you can play it with no risk
always tossing the scrap back out in the yard
but I - I don't play that shit
I play the tough way. Because I take the hard road no matter what it is and I'm gonna beat this thing
with all of the heart inside in my soul
There also are some secrets inside the games themselves
like this fruit maze game and this racer game
have secrets inside them
I can't play them right now because I have no play tokens, so I'm going to see to the end of the game right now
if this is the end of the game I'm about to see [sparkly sound]
and then hopefully, I'm going to be able to get to more of the secrets later
or, get something done
so here we go. I gotta go into this with a lot of concentration
I know that it's not going to go well for me,
but that's fine.
Because I have the eye of the tiger and the ears of a hawk
and everything is in my power to be - to be able to do this
Because I know exactly when you're crawling up my own ass!
and I know how to exactly how to get you out of there
[computer noise] ugh [animatronic noise on right] ooooh hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
No. Stop that. Right now
you stop that. you go back. go back. go back
We can do this, if we're just extremely patient!
[power booting down]
uh hu
ooooooh
Heyy welcome to the party
[Baby Jumpscare] AHH C'mon!
Baby: "You should've known I'd find you"
I shouldn't' have known shit! You just snuck up on me you piece of poo!
Hmmmm
I hear them coming down both ends
Well I think I do
I'm not a hundred percent sure. I think its fine.
[powering down sound]
Oh
oh ... ok?
So there's a noise- there's a noise for them just walking outside the hall
and there's a noise for them actually getting in the vent
and I gotta differentiate between those two noises!
Oooooh noooo! Lally! Lally, Lally, Lally, Lally.
Hey, how's it going?
Don't mind Lally, and me screaming.
me screaming has nothing to do with Lally.
It's got nothing to do with you so you get out of here.
I heard something...I heard somethin-something...
Heard something!
Springtrap: "You may not recognize me at first, but I assure you, it's still me"
Baby [overlapping]: "It feels like home"
[Mark uh-ohing at increasing volumes]
Ayiii! Ayiiii!
I don't know which way to go!
k...
[Loud ad music] [Mark screaming] WACKY WART PASTE NO NO NO NO
Hey, how's it going, you didn't hear anything about no p-wart paste, did you?
[sigh] Nah, you wouldn't know anything about that...
being a dirty, stinking animatronic!
[mumbling] That's right...
Maybe I'm an animatronic...if you wouldn't stop shutting UP!
OH, COME ON!
Okay
Oh, I heard that again! Ugh, just let me see...
Okay, not in the vent, not in the vent, I'm...[grunting]
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine
It's fine. It's fine.
Ugh. Ahhh. I can't tell--agh.
UGHHH
I didn't hear anything, I didn't hear anything for definite certain
but I don't--
Baby: "where are you?"
I'm nowhere, huh!
No! I heard that! Heard that! Heard that
No, no, no
[grunt]
Ho, hey! How's it going there, friend?
You scurry on back, you go back. You go back.
Okay.
Oh, there's one right there.
I didn't finish that task. But that's okay,
because in the face of death I'll- take anything.
As solace.
Okay, we're good.
Oooh.
We're real good.
We're so gooood.
The goodNESS THAT WE HAVE
INSIDE OUR HEARTS
All of the goodness shining out through our- faces
with light and shining brightness
beautiful goodness.
as far as the eye can see.
[grunting]
Springtrap: "Fascinating...what they have become."
[Mark "oh"ing]
Oh!
["oh"ing continues]
Ohhhh! Ahhhh!
I don't know what you're doing but you need to stop now!
[squealing noises]
Okay.
[relieved sigh]
The noisy ass posters are the worst ones!
ah
Ah oooh ooh
ah! dont!
Not now, not now, not now...
Okay, okay,
okay. Just one more complex task and then we're good!
We can get the heckie outta here!
And then we can get the simple ones
ooh oO-oOh
WAAAAA
SQUONKALUNKA LEAVE ME ALONE
please
Please, I'm begging ya
I'm 'bacon' ya
I'm beggin strip ya
I'm gonna bacon beggin' strips ya
I'll give you a beggin' strip if you don't WOOF WOOF OVER HERE
Oh that's *not* good...
Oh, you know what? Oh. That ain't worth the risk.
ooh
WhY WHY
OH, No, no, NO! NOT NOW
NONONO. Stop! NO! NO! NO! NO! NO!
I'M AN OSCILLATING FAN OF DEATH!!!
YOU STAY AWAY FROM ME!!!
[panicked sound]
uh-oh uh-oh uH-OH UH-OH
No... no... no... no...no...
Not like this...
I gotta do something... about it
ok we're fine
[silent gulp]
heh..
UH
I don't hear anything, I don't hear anything
[panicked mumbling]
ah aH AHOOOOH YES
I'M SO GOOD AT THIS GAAAME!
LOOK HOW GOOD I AM, GUYS!
[sigh of ignorant relief]
Scrap Baby: "You played right into our hands."
Did I?
Scrap Baby: "Did you really think that this job just fell out of the sky for you?"
Noooo
Scrap Baby: "No."
No.
Scrap Baby: "This was a gift."
Ahh.
Scrap Baby: "For us."
[quietly] You can shut up now
Scrap Baby: "You gathered them all together in one place"
Aye yi yi.
Scrap Baby: "Just like he asked you to."
Okay, good, good, great great great
Scrap Baby: "All of those little souls"
Scrap Baby: "in one place."
Good, good, great.
Scrap Baby: "Just for us!"
Okay...
Scrap Baby: "A gift."
[blows a kiss]
Scrap Baby: "Now we can do what we were created to do!"
Wow.
Scrap Baby: "And be complete"
Ah, that's not good...
Scrap Baby: "I will make you proud, daddy!"
Scrap Baby: "Watch."
Scrap Baby: "Listen."
Scrap Baby: "And be full!"
[beep] Cassette Man: Connection terminated.
(Nowhere to Run playing) I'm sorry to interrupt you, Elizabeth.
If you still even remember that name.
But I'm afraid you've been misinformed."
You're not here to receive a gift.
Nor have you been called here by the individual you assume.
Although you have, indeed, been called.
You have all been called here.
Into a labyrinth of sounds and smells, misdirection and misfortune.
A labyrinth with no exit.
A maze with no prize.
You don't even realize that you are trapped.
Your lust for blood has driven you in endless circles,
chasing the cries of children in some unseen chamber, always seeming so near,
Yet somehow out of reach.
But you will never find them.
None of you will.
This is where your story ends.
And to you, my brave volunteer,
Who somehow found this job listing not intended for you,
Although there was a way out planned for you,
I have a feeling that's not what you want.
I have a feeling that you are...right where you want to be.
I am remaining as well.
I am nearby.
This place will not be remembered,
and the memory of everything that started this can finally begin to fade away
As the agony of every tragedy should.
And to you monsters trapped in the corridors,
Be still, and...give up your spirits.
They don't belong to you.
For most of you, I believe there is peace, and, perhaps, more,
Waiting for you after the smoke clears.
Although, for one of you,
The darkest pit of Hell has opened to swallow you whole.
So don't keep the devil waiting, old friend.
My daughter, if you can hear me,
I knew you would return as well.
It's in your nature to protect the innocent.
I'm sorry that on that day,
the day you were shut out and left to die.
No one was there to lift you up into their arms the way you lifted others into yours.
And then, what became of you.
I should have known you wouldn't be content to disappear.
Not my daughter.
I couldn't save you then.
So let me save you now.
It's time to rest, for you, and for those you have carried in your arms.
This ends, for all of us.
End communication.
[beep]
Mark: Oh...
[upbeat music]
Tutorial Unit: Congratulations on completing your work week!
We apologize if your situation wasn't presented to you
in a completely honest fashion when you first started.
Mark: [chuckling]
But it was important that your intentions and actions be genuine.
Mark: Haah!
Here at Fazbear Entertainment, we value fun, family, and food,
I bet you do.
Narrator: "but more importantly, we value our commitment to atoning for past mistakes"
"and tying up loose ends."
[Laugh Happily]
"Thank you for your participation."
"There is no need for you to return to work next week, as Fazbear Entertainment is no longer a corporate entity."
"Please accept this certificate of completion."
"Goodbye for now, and thank you for taking this journey with us!"
What???
Oh, I just got a pain through my heart.
Was that the end of everything??
[credit music starts playing]
Oh my god!
Was that the end of everything?!
Molten Freddy, Tutorial Unit, Cassette Man...
Wow!
I think that's really it!
'Cause that wrapped up a lot of actual lore, that gave actual answers.
That was incredible!
That was really fun--and this game is free, by the way!
I don't know if I ever said that--this game, that I'm playing, is free!
It's...[sighs]
Scott!
Wow!
That's--I'm--I'm really, really touched.
And heartbroken, too, because that's the end of it!
And I think this is--
Yeah--this is--The End!
I think this is...
like, the end.
Now I'm not- I'm certain there are other mysteries to be told,
but I think this is, as far as the Five Nights at Freddy's story--like main story, probably goes.
I think this probably wraps up everything.
This-this ties it all up in a bow and...
Man, there it is.
There you have it.
It's crazy.
I guess that's it.
Is there anything more?
There's like--there-there also are the secrets of the-the minigames
inside of it, like the various things.
Even the candy robot--apparently that does tell you stories
if you-if you do go into that.
Now you could go through this game,
and you could play it, like, getting more money with less risk,
and that's always a possibility, but at the same time--
Aw, certificate of completion!
What other certificates are there?!
What other certificates?!
I wanna know!
Aww, I wanna know!!
God...
Uh, but that was really cool.
I got to admit, that was really, really cool.
It was something that was different from the whole Five Nights At Freddy's experience as we know it,
but in a way, it fit so well.
Like the-the simulator aspect of it,
the weirdness, and the funniness, like...
That's what it is. It's not like--
These games aren't, like, solely divided into scariness and uh- uh- thrill, and like
mystery and theories,
it's-it's a mixture of all of it.
And that's what made Five Nights At Freddy's so magical in the first place,
is that it was a fun, satirical, dry humor,
and it-it-it also was extremely terrifying,
and it's that perfect mixture that always made Five Nights at Freddy's so wonderful.
And this game really captured it.
Leaning more on the silliness, but
actually leaning really heavy into the darker tones of it.
It bridged this gap really nicely, and I really enjoyed that.
But before I go, I'm gonna see what happens if I hit continue
on this and see where that leads me.
Is this...it's Saturday.
Ah, okay, so I think I just go through it again.
So.
That's not what it is.
So I'm gonna leave this at this,
And, uh, maybe I will try to beat the other modes.
But thank you everybody so much for watching,
thank you for joining me on this journey of Five Nights at Freddy's,
I know that Five Nights at Freddy's will not be over in the hearts of the fans,
and maybe even Scott will make more Five Nights at Freddy's games in the future,
but as far as the main story goes, I think that is a really nice conclusion
to answer a lot of unanswered questions and get that out there.
So.
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
let me know what you think down in the comments below,
let me know if you want to see more of this and me to dive into the deeper mysteries of it,
and as always,
I will see YOU
in the next video!
BUH-BY [distortion]
[creepy music, computerized voice]
[powering off noise]
3, 2, 1...
[triggered golden freddy jumpscare]